je lui racontais l'histoire qui est
arrivé à nos hazette la maison
qu'habitait noisette avec ses parents
étaient à peu près à deux kilomètres du
village noisette avait 8 ans on l'avait
surnommé ainsi parce que ses yeux
étaient roue comme des noisettes et
qu'il en avait la couleur mais aussi
parce que le chemin qui menait au
village était bordée de noisetiers et
qu'à la bonne saison d'oise est arrivé
sur la grand place avec les poches
pleines de noisette
vous êtes avait beaucoup d'amis avec qui
allait changer des phrases aimables
quand elle venait faire les courses
mais elle ne parlait jamais aux
personnes qu'elle rencontrait sur sa
route et qu'elle ne connaissait pas ses
parents lui avaient interdit cela ne
voulait pas dire qu'ils ne met pas les
étrangers chacun des très bien reçus à
la table familiale ce nom il avait peur
que noisette ne fasse un jour une
mauvaise rencontre
et elle avait toujours obéi un jour
c'était au début du printemps une
méchante fille attendit noisette sur sa
route comme noisette est hélas plus
obéissants de toute la région
la mission de fait avec décidé de la
faire désobéir
c'était une très belle journée et
noisettes était d'excellente humeur en
revenant du village soudain elle a perçu
sur sa route une très belle dame qui
avait l'air très doux et très gentil
c'était la méchante fée qui sait que
transformer bonjour jolie petite fille
dé la table
bonjour madame répond dit poliment
noisette et elle poursuivi son chemin at
on lui dit la dame
je voudrais parler un peu avec toi moi
cette ne voulait pas désobéir
elle ne voulait pas non plus se montrer
à la police non madame répondit-elle
je suis très pressé il faut que je
rentre très vite chez moi et elle
poursuivi sa route
glass art est juste un instant lui dit
la dame je voudrais te donner ses pelles
noisette que j'ai gardées spécialement
pour toi noisette ne put s'empêcher de
marché un peu moins vite
en effet à cette saison les noisettes
n'étaient pas mûrs et à la vue de celle
que le proposait la gentille dame elle
fut saisie d'une envie folle d'en manger
justement j'ai quelques noisettes
ce n'est pas vraiment désobéir s'est dit
c'est elle et elle ralentissait petit à
petit sont pas là michon pfi cru qu'elle
allait gagner
noisette c'était presque arrêté et sa
main se tendaient vers une noisette
mais la méchante fée était si contente
que malgré son visage très doux et très
gentil elle ne put s'empêcher de faire
briller son regard très très très fort
noisette s'en aperçut elle reconnu le
regard d'une méchante fée elle se sauve
a très vite et rentrait chez elle et
toute la région alentour entendit les
éclats de l'ylang scolaire qui saisit la
méchante fée ou faire bravo c'est une
très belle histoire mais mais j'ai eu
très peur que ça finisse mal moi si ça
m'arrivait je n'accepterai jamais les
noisettes
ça vous a plu les enfants c'est un très
vieux combat est ce que vous croyez que
les
les méchants de fées existent non non
c'était toi quasi ça n'existe pas mais
non ça n'existe pas mais je suis sûr que
vos parents vous conseille de ne pas
parler aux personnes que vous ne
connaissez pas et de ne pas accepter de
friandises oui je sais les gens sont
très gentils d'habitude mais il y en a
qui sont un peu fou ou un peu malade et
ils peuvent être méchant avec vous alors
il faut rien accepté oui moi je
n'accepterai jamais un cadeau d'une
personne que je ne connais pas du tout
même si c'était quelque chose que
j'adore avec un grand écart emile bravo
je suis très content de temps de parler
comme ça bon ben casimir raté c'est
parce que julie et moi nous devons aller
au port dans les enfants je sais qu'on
peut vous laisser seuls sans danger à
tout à l'heure milanais au port et ma
boutique qui va la garder les pieds avec
casimir la gare de rap de jules et nous
devons aller au port le port c'est très
loin françois julie julich tout prix
nous devons aller au camp bon alors les
enfants vous amuser bien à tout à
l'heure vous gardez bien à boutiques et
à julie alors moi je vais t'expliquer
voilà ce qu'on reproche aux néons on va
jouer au fond là venez on va jouer au
fond du jardin
après on pourrait bien jouer à trappes
crap
qu'est ce que cette rattrape explique
moi à oui d'accord oui c'est comme chat
perché quoi au ballon oui on va jouer au
ballon d'abord à temps je vois envoi du
crac et on voit bien bien
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
trop loin tu m'as prête un peu ta
patinette car huit minutes
caroline bonjour vous voulez bien parlé
un peu avec moi non je ne voulais pas
manger de mesrine regardez comme elle
brille comme elles sont belles mais plus
fine et hervé vient de voir
bonjour bonjour tu veux parler avec moi
un peu non est ce que tu veux manger de
maîtrise
non mais si non toi le grand c'est moi
grand oui bonjour comment t'appelles-tu
casimir si tu veux bien parler un peu
avec moi je te donnerai mes belles
cerises
oh non non je ne veux pas madame
ah bon pourquoi je n'aime pas les
stories comme ça as tu as tort et vous
avez tous tort mis cerise non seulement
sont belles mais elles ont un pouvoir
spécial
ah oui et locales bien quand on en mange
on lit dans la pensée des autres mais
c'est très intéressant ça j'aimerais
bien lire dans la pensée savoir si les
autres me trouve plutôt intelligent ou
plutôt beau tu peux prendre tout mon
panier
sur la vie mais ces coupes vont aller
gentil et puis c'est très bien de
pouvoir lire dans la pensée des autres
mais c'est joli à l'avenir
tu étais le seul a pas résisté à la
tentation tous les enfants résister à la
tentation sauf toi tu lis dans la pensée
des autres maintenant je crois bien que
oui et que l'étude je ne peux pas vous
le dire devant tout le monde c'est trop
impoli
[Musique]